allez ce mercredi 10 mai le vélodrome
national de 50 ansine a accueilli l'une
des compétitions les plus spectaculaire
du cyclisme sur piste la course à
l'américaine alors l'américaine c'est
une épreuve par équipe de deux coureurs
sachant que c'est une épreuve de relais
donc les coureurs font de ou TR tours ça
dépend à l'allure où ça roule et passe
le relais à leur collègu et puis tous
les plusieurs dizaines de Tours il a des
classementsù les gens doivent prendre
des points pour cette Coupe de France
organisée dans la structure 70 équipes
issues de 13 comités régionaux se sont
inscrites c'est une occasion de se
montrer avec les toutes les équipe qu' a
faireir essayer de faire voir ce qu'on
peut ce qu'on peut donner sur la piste
savoir si on peut se faire prendre dans
dans d'utres catégories ou dans club
c'est important d'être ici parce que on
montre un peu bon déjà les couleurs de
l'ovan ronalp même être ici rouler sur
un aussi beau Vélodrome quand Mme je
suis quand même très content d'y être
sur la piste les cour pas hésiter à
jouer des coues pour emporter la
victoire au péril de leur sécurité il y
a pas toujours la place pour tout le
monde et des fois il y a des coururs qui
veulent passer en dessous alors que par
par code on doit passer au-dessus donc
voilà ça ça frotte notamment chez les
jeunes ne sont pas encore très très
habitués la difficulté de l'Américaine
c'est qu'il vut voir loin et c'est
compliqué de voir loin quand on roule
vite les coureurs qui ont réussi à tenir
sur leur vélo en réalisant les meilleurs
chronos seront qualifiés pour les futurs
championnats de France 2017 la
compétition se déroulera cet
été